hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and black panther
gave us not only one of the best Marvel
movies to date but some of the best new
music we've heard for one of these
movies Kendrick Lamar's soundtrack
featuring collaborations from artists
like the weekends is event staples and
more features powerful deeply dramatic
lyrics and it joins a film score of
traditional African instrumentation by
composer litva göransson all to make
Black Panther sound as amazing as ryan
coogler makes it look so in this video
I'm gonna run through the Black Panther
movie and break down all the moments
where the music both the soundtrack and
the score snuck in some subtle deeper
meaning that you might have missed
that's right this guy's gonna try to
explain rap hey they taught elephants
out of paint
maybe we should all try new things and
yeah spoiler warning in case you haven't
seen Black Panther yet okay the first
song I want to talk about is really one
of the best songs on Kendrick Lamar's
soundtrack titled Kings dead featuring
j-rock Kendrick Lamar future and James
Blake this track is really the anthem
for Michael B Jordans villain character
kill monger channeling his inner
monologue the moment he declares King
T'Challa to be dead and long live King
Angelica actually Kendrick Lamar gives
him a shout out toward the end of the
song now in my in-depth breakdown a
black panther I pointed out how the
characters of T'Challa and kill monger
reflect the longtime debate in the civil
rights movement between figures like
Martin Luther King jr. and Malcolm X
King was known for preaching
non-violence symbolic gestures while
Malcolm X preached action and violence
if necessary to combat racism in society
a philosophy kill monger takes to an
extreme this tracks title of King's dead
could also reflect the shift the civil
rights movement took following that
King's death when many felt it signaled
a time for a more extreme action and for
something a little less heavy I just
love the nod future gave me three 6
mafia hear this soundtracks for Disney
movie guys I love this but let's move on
to talk quickly about this movie's
original score composed by Luke Vig
göransson from the movie's earliest
scenes this composer identifies the hero
and villain with opposing instruments
that he discovered while traveling
through West Africa for research for
T'Challa he uses something called the
talking drum something that was used in
Senegalese villages for communication it
can be adjusted for pitch to reflect the
sound of the hue
boys meanwhile for kill monger the
composer used the hula flute or tambon
you can hear the talking drum playing
underneath several seats throughout the
film including two challahs battle
within Baku to claim the throne but then
later when he battles kill monger the
drum in the flute clash with each other
in the music just like the characters
are clashing in their fight and another
scene if you listen closely when
T'Challa and the Kia stroll through the
streets of Wakanda yonks and samples
more traditional West African music this
time from the country of Mali a song
called Bouree Bouree by addresses some
borrow featuring a leaf architour a
apologies if I mispronounced any of it
along with these shots of bumbling
trolleys and vendors grilling chicken
this music makes the street level of
Wakanda feel so grounded and authentic
now another example of traditional West
African music being linked with a
character later on in the South Korean
casino director Ryan Coogler pointed out
in an analysis of the scene another
interesting musical cues also another
thing is music year naka pause a little
bit gone on to some beautiful music and
this is where you hear the door acute
there's a group of women in Senegal
doing a yeah like a tutu
yeah you can hear these Senegalese women
chirping every time the jordan lodge
they fights throughout the movie
actually if you listen closely they come
up during King's dead as well actually
this whole sequence in South Korea is
filled with interesting these examples
first when they roll up in Busan you can
hear the song hangover by Korean
musician psy and Snoop Dogg but then
once they enter the club the music
shifts to another song from the
soundtrack pray for me by the weekend
and Kendrick Lamar the lyrics here
explored the burdens of being a hero how
that responsibility often falls on one
person's shoulders as they have to face
these struggles alone all this expresses
what's going through two challahs mind
here he has just become the ruler of a
nation yet it's still on him to carry
out the responsibilities of the warrior
on this mission to be the hero next when
the action moves outside and this
amazing car chase music shifts to the
amazing track called ops by Vince
staples and you
electron this music actually showed up
at one of the later trailers for Black
Panther and while the beat and staples
lyrics are just so intense and charged
the song takes on a whole new life in
the second verse when you give Black
Rock takes over she's a young upstart
rapper from South Africa and her lyrics
are just as proud and boastful as
staples are together these two reflects
T'Challa ensure ease cooperation here
sure he's driving a Lexus remotely and
T'Challa is riding it with the goal
being to chase down claw and the stolen
vibranium ultimately their takedown of
Klaw is reflected in these lyrics as
well when charged with stealing
vibrating from Wakanda Klaw responds
racist Lee you savages wouldn't know
what to do with it this idea of white
colonizers plundering African resources
and economic oppression is yeah one of
the many things staples targets with his
lyrics okay in the movies final scene -
Chawla and Cherie visit the Oakland
project where their father killed their
uncle and the music we had sampled here
is sleepwalking by mozzie mozzies from
Northern California like Ryan Coogler so
it looks like koogler wanted to include
a local artist for this scene but when
the credits roll the music that plays is
the big single from the soundtrack all
the stars by Kendrick Lamar in season
now I highly suggest you check out the
music video for this it's beautifully
shot and it reflects a lot of the
afro-futurist aesthetic that production
designer Hannah Beach lerk reiated for
this movie but really it's scissors
chorus that underlies the theme of this
moment all the stars are closer suggests
that for once the oppressed and
underprivileged are actually in arm's
reach of their dreams in this case it's
a kid on the streets of Oakland he's
closer than ever to a future he'd never
could have imagined the port a badass
superhero and king who looks like him
empowered by a magical element that
originated from as the movies opening
shots showed us all the stars but I'm
curious to hear from you guys which of
these musical cues got you most pumped
while watching Black Panther for me
those sin uglies women's sharp enduring
Ryan Coogler is awesome one take
tracking shot legacy no it was just
perfect but I'd comment with your
thoughts down below or tweet me directly
at us and follow new rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
our videos and of course subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of black
panther check out my in-depth breakdown
for all the movies design details and
easter eggs and for more music analysis
like this check out some other videos I
did for the musical
where's the last Jedi in last year's
baby driver and if you really love us
and you wanna help us grow you can
contribute to this channel on patreon
big thanks to all of our donors
especially Wilhelmina ever send guys
thanks for watching bye